I remember I had Marianne Williamson on my show and I told her, you know,
I really don't watch the news. And she goes, that's, you need to watch the news.
Like you need to be informed, especially as like a white male,
you need to know what's happening in the world.
And the moment you can get the news from different places.
I don't need to watch the TV to get the news. I can check, you know,
Apple news or whatever, or get someone to tweet me something and check it out.
And people are to tell you the news, no matter what.
Right, right. You can't, you can't really escape the news. I try to focus on.
I truly believe that when I focus on giving to people and service,
I'm a happier human being. And,
and research has backed science of happiness that when you're in contribution to
someone else, whether it's opening the door, buying a coffee,
having a conversation,
listening to someone when they're going through something, doing charity work,
whatever it may be that makes you the happiest when we're giving to others.
So I don't want to do straight up politics.
I did not get an essay book of the things that you won't talk about,
but I don't want to do politics because I think it's a good escape. This is,
this is meta politics course. Um, but in a time,
like we live in right now where politics seems crazy,
everyone's trying to destroy each other, all of those things.
Do you have any tricks that you use for yourself or that you've recommended to
other people to scale back? I mean,
one of the things I try to show people is that your worldview just can't be
political. You, you, you know, if your worldview is just politics,
you're always doing this,
you've got blinders on and you need a much bigger philosophical, religious,
whatever it is, whatever your worldview is, it needs to be much wider.
Do you have any tricks? Because it seems like everyone everywhere.
And I know I'm sort of self-selected into the stage.
When anyone sees me at the store, they want to talk politics. But,
but I do sense people. It's making people crazier. It's making people angrier.
Uh, you know,
they just released this big study about how depressed people are right now. And.
I, uh,
I remember when I started being an entrepreneur, um,
after leaving my brothers,
I pay two 50 a month for my brother's place to have a room from his place.
Right. And I started making enough money to get an apartment for, uh,
four 95 a month. And it was the scariest thing to write a check for four 95.
Cause I was like, I don't know how I'm going to pay this next month.
But I got the cheapest department I could in Columbus, Ohio. Um, and I remember,
and I didn't have a car at the time. So I was walking everywhere.
And I remember saying to myself, I'm not going to get a TV.
And the first few years I didn't have a TV.
And I just focused on my mission and my vision, which was creation,
which was getting customers and sales and adding value to those customers and
clients and not having a TV was a big blessing.
I love movies and I love TV. So I would go to the movies all the time,
but I wouldn't allow myself to browse and see chaos on a screen
until midnight, and then go to sleep with nightmares from the,
so personally, I try to,
I remember I had Marianne Williamson on my show and I told her, you know,
I really don't watch the news. And she goes, that's, you need to watch the news.
Like you need to be informed, especially as like a white male,
you need to know what's happening in the world.
And the moment you can get the news from different places.
I don't need to watch the TV to get the news. I can check, you know,
Apple news or whatever, or get someone to tweet me something and check it out.
And people are gonna tell you the news, no matter what, right. You can't,
you can't really escape the news. I try to focus on. Yeah.
I truly believe that when I focus on giving to people and service,
I'm a happier human being. And,
and research has backed science of happiness that when you're in contribution to
someone else, whether it's opening the door, buying a coffee,
having a conversation,
listening to someone when they're going through something, doing charity work,
whatever it may be that makes you the happiest when we're giving to others.
So when we're focused on self and what we don't have suffering is the
result of obsessive. Self-centric thinking. So when I'm thinking of the news,
this is not working in my favor. I need to, this is an outrage,
or I'm not happy about this because it's not helping me.
You're going to be unhappy.
And I'm not saying you shouldn't fight for what you want and, and,
and have things to change. Sure. But if you're going to be,
if you want to be happier, focus on other people,
focused on service and also don't watch the news.
And as media companies, ourselves, we won't be able to watch us.
But I think watch, um,
focus on things that bring you joy. I think as adults,
we don't play enough. You know, in my, in my studio,
I've got a Frisbee and I'll, and we love to work hard. You know,
our team works hard, but I'll grab Matt or CLL or my friend. And I say,
we need five minutes just to throw the Frisbee.
Like we need to play who plays anymore. Especially if we can't go outside,
you can't do this. Who's playing well, I'm chasing a one-year-old dog. Exactly.
Right. So that, but I'm like a big advocate of play.
We're watching TV, go do something fun.
I went out to was it I've been in LA for eight years.
How long have you been here? Uh, about eight years. Eight years. Seven,
literally two days ago. First time I went to, uh,
Franklin Canyon Lake or park. Have you been in this place?
I don't even know what that is. This is 10 minutes from here.
It's a Lake and nature of like a hundred acres in the middle of LA.
You can't see the city. It's literally in the middle of Mohan drive.
Never heard of this place. It's unbelievable. I saw a photo of an audience.
We got a link there.
We got a Lake and it's like ducks and turtles and everything. Yeah.
And I went there on Sunday with my girlfriend and our dog. And it was just like,
we're in nature. We're hanging out. I'm not watching TV.
I'm not on social media. I'm a big salsa dancer. I love slowly.
For 15 years of my salsa dancing around the world. I play guitar.
I like to play sports workout. I'm just like,
go do something that's going to and benefit your life and contribute and benefit
someone else's life. When you do those things,
you're going to be a better person. I'm learning Spanish.
I'm trying all these different things that give me a way from the train wreck of
the news. So that's what I recommend. Don't obsess yourself into.
What's not working for you. Go be the change.
Do you sense that right now? Because of grown-up protests,
because everything is, is so seemingly chaotic,
that people are becoming more receptive to the type of stuff you're talking
about. Because I can just, for me,
like I started gardening since we started doing this.
I'll show you when we get out here, we got a ton of it.
We're growing a ton of great stuff out there. I got carrots, I got,
I got tomatoes, I got cucumbers. I got zucchini. I got broccoli, uh, peppers.
But like I started doing that. I'm cooking a lot more.
David usually cooks a ton, but now I'm barbecuing all the time.
And like I'm refining some skills. And like,
I think there's a unique opportunity in this mess to either come out of it,
more skilled, more refined, more passionate about what you do,
or maybe realize that what you were doing before and what you want to do were
all that stuff.
Versus some people that I think are just gonna have slogged through it and not
really thought about their life critically enough.
And then they'll just be on the other side in the world.
I'm on both sides here. I, if you,
if you need to take a pause and rest for these last three months,
because you've been, go, go, go, go, go nonstop for 10 years.
And you had never taken a pause in your life.
This is the most beautiful time for you to sit around and do nothing and read a
book and lounge and not hustle. So for some people,
I think that is what you need. And personally,
my philosophy is I feel like this is what the world needed in general is for us
to take a pause with technology being so fast with us on social media.
Most people are on their phones, six, seven, eight hours a day.
And a lot of it's social media. It's like, what are we consuming our time with?
It's not what we're supposed to be doing all day.
Pretty sure it's not making us happier. It's something that's happier.
It's making us more neurotic of like,
I need more likes and more followers I need to, Oh,
what's happening in the news. It's just, it's craziness. And so for some,
I think don't do anything. And that's what you need.
You need to reevaluate why your life isn't working, why this relation,
I'm seeing so many people. I'm not sure if you're seeing this,
a lot of big personalities are posting. We're getting a divorce.
We're going through a breakup. You're finally evaluating your relationship.
What's the point. You're,
you're trapped in a house with someone every minute for three months,
go and do it. Do I like this?
You can't escape anymore.
So I think people are getting clear on what they want because they haven't been
clear for a long time, maybe partly but not fully.
So for some people you need a pause. You need a break. You need to evaluate,
you need to take inventory of everything in your life and create a new game
plan. Moving forward.
You need to find some coaches and mentors and have a game plan and go take
action for other people. I'm kind of in the middle.
I feel like I've hustled more. My business, I've hired more people.
I've been like more creative than ever,
but I'm also going to the park and with my girlfriend, my dog on the weekends,
which I would never do. And I'm taking that time to be in nature.
So I feel like I'm trying to do both and bounce my personal life,
but then work going kind of all in and getting clear, like,
what is our audience need right now? What does our customers need?
What are the need for the next five to 10 years? If this doesn't change.
So I'm a little in the middle and I have empathy for both sides,
but I think if you can rediscover what you want to do in your life and who you
want to become, whether you take action on it now, or just discover it now,
that's what.
How do you decide how much stuff to put out there in the midst of all this?
Because a lot of what you're talking about is to ease up on this stuff,
go live your life, get out there in nature, et cetera, et cetera.
I think I mentioned to you last time, like people say to me, Dave,
why don't you do an interview every day, do five interviews a week,
do seven interviews a week. And we do one or two.
And then I obviously do some other stuff. And I, it's not for a lack of time,
but it really, in many cases for a respect of my audience, people saw.
Yeah. Like it's. Cause I it's like if you listen to me,
then hopefully you listened to one of your episodes.
Maybe you listen to Sam Harris or Joe Rogan or whatever. It's like,
I want you to, that's great. If you give a couple hours a week to this stuff,
that's fantastic, but I don't want you to give 40 hours of your week to,
I don't even want you to give 20 hours of your week to, to this. So like,
I think it's important what we're doing, it's valuable what we're doing,
but how do you decide like what's enough and what's too much.
Three factors. One is like, what is my audience?
What I think my audience wants and my intuitive side of what they think they are
going to want or need what works for me personally.
Like I don't want to be on every day doing an interview either.
It's a lot of energy. What personally works for my life and my lifestyle,
my vision for the future. And then what does the data say?
If you'd like to be inspired, motivated,
and educated by some of the most successful people around the world,
check out the school of greatness, full episode playlist right over here.
And if you'd like to see Lewis house's interview with me,
click right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.